we're an island nation our history and
our identity intimately connected to the
ocean but some things threatening the
seas around us it's plastic here in our
beautiful waters
in the very foundations of marine life
getting into the food we eat I've joined
a team of women that wants to know more
about what's going on
together we'll embark on a journey an
expedition around the UK we're going to
be tested to our very limits
[Music]
there'll be unexpected events some
magical moments
one two three
and as many science experiments as we
can manage so can we do it can a boat
full of strangers rise to this challenge
can we learn more about the water that
sustains life on earth this is the story
of a group of women and our voyage of
discovery it all starts in Plymouth we
get a few minutes to stow our gear and
find our bunks thank you sorry this is
not much space but that is the way it
works on a boat these women have each
paid for their place on the expedition a
month-long journey around the UK
measuring for plastics and raising
awareness as we go a professional crew
will be looking after us
we have a day moored in the harbor to
learn the basics and then we begin
dan Reed is our skipper some of her crew
have sailed before others like me have
little experience at sea out of the port
and into open water aboard our boat a 72
foot expedition yacht called sea dragon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah it's great
this is my favorite thing we're sailing
from Plymouth around Lands End up the
bristol channel to Cardiff
[Music]
to start with all is calm in the evening
Sun but there's bad weather ahead and we
sail right into it
against the wind with choppy waves
it's a horrible combination most of the
boat starts feeling queasy they're sick
on a side the Atlantic Ocean is
merciless and it's a rough start
a very long two days later things
finally start to get better Vanessa a
fish buyer for a supermarket emerges I
found myself in tears sitting in the
saloon having my own two-year-old
tantrum fellow well aware that it's a
tantrum but really wanting to just be
home and wanting all the movement just
to stop but mainly were disappointed
because we haven't been able to do any
science we feel a bit defeated the bad
weather has delayed us and skipper Diane
has to race into Cardiff Bay before the
tide is too low for the boat we're
trying to squeeze in to the lock before
the gate closes literally not just
figuratively my skipper's Ange tells me
we're going to make it but we're also
going to be very very careful when it
over the sill because we might have
literally a few centimeters to clear we
make it just
[Music]
after all the challenges in the last few
days getting into Cardiff Bay feels like
a real achievement it was actually these
things have a bonding effect 14 women
who didn't know each other before the
journey started and now we know they're
really well they're too well having seen
each other in all sorts of different
terrible states and that's actually been
very good for team spirit now we're all
feeling better the sun's out while we've
been at sea the expedition's two
youngest ambassadors have been traveling
upstream Amy and Ella meek have founded
a campaign called kids against plastic
they're too young to sail with us on sea
dragon instead they're tackling the
problem of plastic pollution wherever
they find it I caught up with Ella and
dad Tim in Cardiff how are you good
we're picking up litter close to the bay
that's how microplastics get into the
water we find disintegrating straws all
over the ground that's one of your big
four plastics
isn't it what are they again straws
coffee cups and lids yep bottles and
bags so we can stop selling and using
those musil's does anything make a
difference can we make a difference with
this little clean here sort of what's
the point why we're doing this yeah what
are we achieving yeah so we're trying to
pick up a hundred thousand pieces of
single-use beverage plastic that for us
relates to the figure of a hundred
thousand see my hostel
engagement on shore is a vital part of
this mission so we hold a reception on
board sea dragon for people interested
in what we're doing just a few metres
away under the steps of the Welsh
Assembly Building itself a reminder that
plastic pollution is everywhere this is
really really important this is about
getting it up the agenda getting at the
forefront of people's minds and and
really like discussing like the
multi-faceted Ness of the of the issue
like we need to tackle it all together
we need politicians to listen to us we
need industry to know that we care about
this and that we want the change now
time's up in Cardiff the duties have
been allocated we'll work around the
clock to make it to the next port my
first night shift this evening is 4 a.m.
to 8 a.m.
taffy breaks
[Music]
I have actually where I actually get
some time stuff which is British and
they're seizing
so we're off off to Belfast across the
Irish Sea two nights and a day of
sailing see you on the other side
but we don't get very far first mate
Hawley is trying to find out what has
set off the alarm
just to advise you we have had to stop
engines and we're just drifting outside
the channel moment I have found a
beautiful bit of plastic which is a very
potential source of why we can get water
into our engine plastic shitty shitty
plastic language shitty plastic but the
problem still isn't fixed we can't work
out what's wrong and we're not going
anywhere
six days into the voyage with hardly any
science done the pressure is on
[Music]
our sailing expedition around the UK has
ground to a halt we're stuck in the
Bristol Channel because our engines not
working we thought we'd found the
problem a piece of plastic sucked into a
filter plastic but now everything's put
back together we're still not moving
just like we would our water moving
through the system yet so I've gone back
to two things there made that piece of
plastic that we have may have only been
one of it may have been more Diane and
Holly keep searching
that is a full blockage it smells like a
fish actually where's your scientist in
all their combined decades at sea the
professional crew have never seen such a
thing but there's no time to dwell on it
we need to get going
and we're about to hoist anchor just
outside to be on our way
we're making our way out of the Bristol
Channel across the Irish Sea and to
Belfast
[Music]
it's choppy but we have our sea legs now
lovely to get the sails up and finally
make some progress
as night falls there are trolls below
deck to do Lin and I tackle the worst
one pumping the bilges the next day
conditions are right to start trolling
and this is a very fine match to collect
microplastics
anything else but nothing is
straightforward at sea
a curious gracile comes to investigate
and we can't risk it getting tangled in
our lines got another 20 minutes to wait
now guys at long last the science is
under way ready
[Music]
this trawl collect samples from the
ocean's surface even tiny particles are
plastic it's one of our most important
pieces of kit time to investigate the
contents are filtered through sips of
different sizes and examined I found
bits of plastic with organisms growing
on it and then I also found bits of what
looked to be micro fibers floating out
of guts of a fish translate me test it
out so we can anything even the unlucky
eel in the engine is fair game under the
microscope Tania found 11 micro fibers
and a small piece of hard plastic in his
digestive tract
while we get to grips with the water
pump now far out into the Irish Sea some
visitors arrive
their presence prompts a discussion
about protecting this habitat ceratin
Bern is a writer sailor and management
consultant the fashion to drink water
out of single-use plastic water bottles
is an incredibly destructive piece of
very clever marketing so well you know
actually Falls to that I don't want your
marketing stuff that just drops crap all
over my streets gets into my oceans and
destroys my food chain I'm not
interested in it so how do we encourage
people who we want to be hydrate if you
want to be healthy to drink the very
good chap fortune which way do you know
you kingdom up history so at 25 miles
away from dock time to get dressed at an
angle and up on deck for a last push to
Belfast
Dyanne demonstrates crucial sailing
skills like how to eat hot food in the
rain while helming
[Music]
we're all drenched but there's no time
to stop and dry off it's straight from
the boat onto a beach clearly a
tradition now for the crew of sea dragon
this one is the worst yet you can hear
the plastic crunching under our feet
it's heartbreaking to see it happen
everywhere it's layers deep you move it
apart and something looks clean or at
least mildly clean and it's just not it
has to end from the source it has to be
people disposing of their trash in the
right way it has to be companies finding
product you know finding different ways
to produce their product so that doesn't
create this kind of waste that's been
down there just growing underneath the
preface it's ridiculous the rubbish
piles up crew member and artist Deborah
more put some of it on display at a
local cafe mostly what we got were
bottles bottle caps and then a lot of
ducks I said someone's had a duck I
thought in the race it's out of sight
out of mind because it's like nobody
then thinking where do these end up and
what happens to them so how many banks
did we get from the [ __ ] team at 55 how
much time did it take together 90
minutes 55 bags of 19
any chance you can just grab the passage
plan book before we leave Belfast the
crew gathers for a briefing on the next
part of the journey
Diane has some news this is hurricane
Curt hi Gert we were planning to sail
right around the coast of Scotland we
have 40 knots potentially that we're
gonna see which is a lot of winds this
boat could handle it but it won't allow
us to do science it could jeopardize the
whole project to go so we're not gonna
go instead we are going to create a
whole new opportunity and that is to go
through the Caledonian canal the crew
works late into the night to plan our
new routes we are casting off and on our
way out we're heading north up to
Scotland for the final part of leg one
it's a short hop from Belfast to lamb
lash Bay in Aran this is a crew
transformed these are our biggest seas
yet but instead of being sick we're
having fun
the wind is behind us pushing us along
[Applause]
I'm starting to understand why people
get hooked on sailing
almost there first mate Polly has to get
the sail packed away not easy in these
conditions
one final effort and we're into the
shelter of lamb lash BAE
all in a day's work for the professional
crew he drops the main and some quite
hairy conditions but Holly was kind of
Awesome
uh I was 13 Holly no I've got guns of
Steel anyway so it's alright we spend
the night at anchor celebrating the end
of this part of our adventure in the
morning we head to shore to tell people
about our mission and why it matters
first we catch up with our land-based
ambassadors Amy and Ella meek they're
here with their mum Kerry to talk to
some local schoolchildren about ocean
plastic we both seem really passionate
about the issue can you try and explain
why it's sort of fires you like that
what really gets me about plastic
pollution is that I mean this isn't
going away plastic stays around forever
and whilst our generation might not have
been the ones to literally manufacture
this this problem we're gonna be the
ones left to fix it especially as the
action that kind of needs to be taken on
a global scale isn't being taken and so
we're really passionate about it because
we know that this problem is only gonna
grow and we want to make it a smaller
legacy that we're gonna win her as
possible that's also the mission of X
expedition the organization running our
trip
Emily Penn is one of its founders we're
trying to tackle this issue of ocean
plastics of toxic said many of these
environmental challenges and that are a
kind of big hard and the goal posts are
always moving and we need to be really
flexible and adaptable in the way we
work so we can navigate these big global
challenges and you know what we've been
presented with here on this trip is a
really great little micro version of
that
some new crew members have arrived for
the next leg of the journey and they'll
soon experience that firsthand time to
head out to see dragon and prepare to
leave before the weather closes in Lam
lash Bay in the Isle of Arran
and skipper Diane is preparing new crew
members for the next part of the journey
before leaving some trawl samples need
to be handed over Winnie Court and Jones
is a PhD student studying how
microscopic pieces of plastic affect the
oceans she's arrived to pick up some of
what's been collected so far here we've
got the samples from the man turtle so
I'm gonna analyze the microplastics and
see the quantity and what types of
plastic we have in that for all of the
mission we'll hear more from Winnie
later but with samples safely delivered
it's time to leave the bay the crew has
been forced to change course to avoid
the tail end of a hurricane that's
heading towards the west coast of
Scotland the new route takes sea dragon
out from the Firth of Clyde up to Fort
William and along the Caledonian canal
to Inverness and Edinburgh there's a bit
of hard going to start with
but as they reached the shelter of Loch
lynnie the crew is rewarded with some of
the most spectacular views in Britain
[Music]
it's on to Fort William and the
Caledonian canal the shortcut for boats
through land to the north sea sea dragon
is carefully maneuvered into the first
of 29 locks as the crew negotiates
neptune's staircase it's a real change
of pace one benefit is a steady supply
of people to talk to about the cause the
first series of gates are left behind
and sea dragon is under motor there are
60 miles of canals through the Great
Glen soon the narrow passage gives way
to a series of freshwater locks with the
most famous just ahead
[Music]
fort augustus and the first glimpse of
one of Scotland's most celebrated sights
Loch Ness
a chance for some science in
breathtaking surroundings one two three
the manta trawl is launched into the PG
waters of the lot this bit of the
journey has given the crew a chance to
find out how much plastic is in some of
our inland waterways
in comes the net for a first look
brilliant it doesn't take long for Emily
Pen to spot something that really
shouldn't be there so we found a little
piece there that bright blue color
really obvious in nature this isn't the
only experiment being done on board the
crew are also monitoring plankton the
tiny organisms at the bottom of the food
chain there are the canary in the
coalmine of the oceans and it's really
important to understand them this is
something that has really allowed us to
gain a huge amount of very detailed
on-the-ground information most
phytoplankton most plankton research is
done from satellites and it's very
difficult to sometimes understand what's
really happening in the water but to get
an even better idea of what's going on
under the surface the team has enlisted
expert help at the Scottish Association
for marine science
winny Colton Jones is taking a first
look at some of the trawl samples this
is a sample that they collected with the
manta nets around belfast you can see a
large number of zooplankton we've also
got quite a lot of fibers this is just a
tiny amount from this one sample that
was collected you can see a much higher
density of microplastics and indeed
zooplankton as well scientists don't yet
fully understand the impact of plastic
entering the base of the food chain but
it's still worrying it's a concern for
all organisms it's easier to study
there's large individuals like seabirds
and whales and turtles but the
zooplankton and the planet in that we
don't really see with our naked eyes
i've been found to ingest large amounts
of plastic these are the foundation
species of life on our planet so the
fact that they're ingesting
microplastics I think is a reason for
concern
one last challenge before sea dragon
reaches open water looming in the
distance is Kecak bridge and it's going
to be a tight
to get under there restriction is 29
meters and we are 29 meters of aircraft
and at the moment our math looks good
we'll have about 48 to go under the
bridge number crunching done and the
only thing for it is some early morning
yoga
[Music]
then comes the moment of truth
Oh
[Music]
the road bridge is no match for Diane
and seadragon and they head out towards
Edinburgh
currently living life with a bit of an
apple walking around is rated school we
have so done
it's a typical North Sea welcome I am on
the lookout because
[Music]
but the crew still manages to sample the
water that's churning around them and on
the approach to Edinburgh make a
discovery nasty nurdle these nurdles are
in fact small pellets used to produce
plastic products they're easily spilled
and hard to see
[Music]
okay whew oh dear
it's alright we've got it it's all
useful ammunition for what's to come
[Music]
during the next few days in Scotland's
capital the aim is outreach and
influence
so it's time to bring our most effective
persuaders the missions junior
ambassadors Amy and Ella meek to a
meeting at the Scottish Parliament
they've been tracing our journey on land
and have a compelling message to deliver
we use around 7 million single-use
coffee cups and there was 30 million
plastic bottles every single day in the
UK alone there's no excuse for using the
amount of plastic that we do and there's
definitely no excuse for not doing
anything about it
remember plastic has been around for
less than a century and we've already
made it into one of the largest
environmental threats facing mankind
today this is our problem a completely
man-made one so it's up to us to fix it
not how I imagined I'd be spending
fringe sodding
down the road we have a chance to make a
different kind of impact crew member and
artist Katie Turnbull is creating an
installation using plastic from a beach
clean and litter from the Edinburgh
Festival three minutes sandwich that's
like three minutes on the coffee five
minutes for this burger 15 minutes on
this bag like it's just such a short
amount of time and then compare it to
the time it's gonna last fall we are now
in the year twenty four seventeen and
you have time traveled four hundred
years into the future and we really
actually are here to get your help in a
lab space nearby it's getting even more
creative you can see it on the screen
but if you want to get a closer look in
the microscope the crew is putting on an
immersive show to highlight our
addiction to plastic bottles plastic
bottles and plastic bags have you heard
of this in 2017 was this a thing it
seems it we we don't we don't judge the
experience is designed to help us
confront some uncomfortable truths about
how we live our lives so have a look but
can we change it is gonna take time it's
gonna take education it's gonna take
sort of environmental justice campaigns
as well because that's such a serious
issue when it comes to this but you've
got hope I've got two and honestly as a
historian these things are secular and
society has in many ways come to a
horrific point in the past and we have
managed to emerge and that's maybe what
my optimism is founded into
plenty to think about as we prepare to
leave Edinburgh they're our longest
stretch at sea yet there's something
great about having this tiny little
environment that you have to manage on
your own and what you've got on board is
what you get to use so in a way it's
quite good practice really for what
we're talking about this thought of
having to use less and being careful
about what you choose to use oh my god
this is beautiful
with all of that in mind we're
london-bound heading out into the North
Sea and the challenges that lie ahead
[Music]
it's the final part of our journey to
investigate the plastic hidden in our
waters we're making our way out of
Edinburgh and the new crew members are
settling in
[Music]
we'll be sailing through the North Sea
around the East Coast along the Thames
to London after a stop in a capital
we're heading back to Plymouth where our
journey began diana popilius the
missions lead scientist is now on board
under her guidance over the next 10 days
we'll do as much sampling as we can now
maybe there its organisms maybe it's
micro process that passed bass rock home
to a huge colony of gannets a reminder
of the other species who depend on the
ocean the animals out here have no
choice there they're living in this
stuff they can't go to the supermarket
and pick something else out they can't
decide I'm gonna eat soy instead of fish
because now we think fish is
contaminated our fast here and here and
then car death leg one crew member Lynn
Bram has brought mussels we've been
collecting to Hull University here
scientists use chemicals to dissolve
tissue and reveal what's left over often
its microplastics to be honest I go
through stages where I don't sleep very
well but it's not just microplastics
there work on all types of different
contaminants in the environment and when
you add them all together it is quite
worrying and I do worry for the next
generation if you like I have a daughter
and that that's what really gets to me
is I wonder about what's what problems
are we storing up for them in the future
out in the North Sea we pause to take in
the sunrise we're about to receive some
worrying news a diver has gone missing
vessels in the area have been asked to
keep a lookout sort of the rules of the
road of sailing that if ever you hear a
distress message and you are able to
help because you're in the area and
you're you've got the facilities then
it's pretty much the law that you need
to help out anyone you can we continue
with our journey searching as we go and
something is spotted in the water
in these circumstances any potential
sighting must be followed up Diane
initiates a Man Overboard drill it's not
what we hope to find there were two a
second sighting this time an even larger
clump of balloons miles from the shore
it's a happy birthday balloon and you
can see that it's a two year olds
birthday which is lovely and I wish the
child in question Oh a very happy
birthday the sad thing about this is
that this balloon which is probably
quite fresh it's still got a lot of its
gold color on it so the child is
probably still only two the balloon in
the marine environment will last a lot
longer than the child this would stay in
the sea breaking down into smaller and
smaller but still very toxic pieces for
hundreds of years
sadly the search is called off and we
say Ilan we're in the middle of our
longest period at sea three days and
three nights of sailing but the wind is
with us and we speed down to London VTS
sea dragon we are now within sight of
the barrier over but the best is yet to
come oh it's lifting Tower Bridge is
being raised for sea dragon
after all the weeks of sailing it is a
magical moment
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's quickly back to reality though as
seadragon pulls over to wait for a space
to dock but we do have some single-use
plastic intentional but the pile of
trash is in some ways useful offering us
a chance to think about the challenge of
consuming less votes a very good
training for living in a small world
because it is you know folks at sea is a
small world and we only have one planet
we're living as if you've got three
despite the sight and smell next to us
Co mission leader sue is delighted as a
big moment wasn't it
what's made you so emotional I've been
working on this for 18 months and the
fact that we were able to come back
through the bridge and into our birth
just in time for mooring up the rains
arrived welcome to London now it's the
Capitals turn to hear the message this
time via art made from plastic collected
on the banks of the Thames we catch up
with the meek family before the girls
head back to school we've had an amazing
response from the people that we've
spoken to and just a really positive
vibe movemove people really keen to take
action and try and combat issue and do
you think oh that people have been more
willing to listen
well actually being kids people do think
oh wait there's a kid telling me not to
use plastic maybe I should listen
the girls inspired you to care more
about plastics yeah it's you know our
mindset no it's just even if we're
thirsty and the only thing that we could
get in any way we could get water was to
buy a plastic bottle we'd go thirsty
you know we're that we're that committed
and we would feel like we would not were
not doing the right thing if we resort
to these convenience plastics with sea
dragon moored in such an iconic location
it's another chance to reach as many
people as we can do you think that this
mission will have made it
on these big issues think it's really
hard to say now I think it's it's yeah
it's little changes that just sort of
magnify over time I think we've
definitely made a difference to the
women that have sailed with us yeah and
I think they they're going to become
powerful ambassadors we've seen that in
the past I don't doubt for a second that
they won't have this in their
consciousness for the rest of their
lives
[Music]
early morning and the crews ready to
leave London we cast off for the last
time stop rabbiting on
sampling the water in the Thames as we
go in a very full so we're gonna be here
for some time
probably about ten nice how many years
will it take for the license to break it
down it never breaks down
it's worse in Deborah's civ duckweed
crunchy with microbeads as I'm really
poking around in it if all these colors
are jumping out it's like well this is
what we've been talking about and it's
full of them and this was just the tiny
sample of Thames Water the act of
bearing witness is having a profound
effect on some of the new crew members
you can't unknow this you can't go back
to how you were things have to change
for me it's it's a real tipping point in
what I need to do going forward it's
it's really brought home that yes it's a
problem people talk about it people it's
growing awareness but actually we have
to do something really quickly
but problem-solving has to wait a lucky
run with the weather ends and the last
phase of the journey is a tough one when
it all stops we are rewarded a reminder
if we needed it that the ocean is a
special place
[Music]
the harbor beckons sea dragon has come
full circle
so the see is what cracks us and the
ocean is what holds us together and we
tend to think of the ocean as a divider
awaits a you might row and for me that's
been really strong mind with you for now
though it's time to say goodbye I've
been inspired by these women and their
desire to rise to this vast complex
challenge and because of this experience
many of us are going home
with a new understanding of what's at
stake we've had a truly unforgettable
journey around our beautiful islands and
ultimately one full of hope that making
a difference protecting these precious
waters turning the plastic tide is
within our reach
[Music]
you